- This video is brought to you by Raycon.
(upbeat electronic music)
What's up, guys?
Helen here to talk about your favorite
brooding masked crusader.
Yep, Batman's back,
complete with the film noir
inspired aesthetic to go
with all his emo feelings.
Fittingly, "The Batman"
is all about playing
with lightness and darkness,
both visually and thematically.
Specifically, it's
exploring which of Gotham's
hidden truths are exposed to the light
and which remain shrouded
in darkness and lies.
So pull out those AA batteries
and get your flashlight ready
for this Wisecrack quick
take on "The Batman."
How much truth can one society handle?
And, of course, spoilers
ahead for the new Batman.
But before we get into it,
I wanna tell you about this
video's sponsor, Raycon.
Raycon's everyday earbuds look sleek
and bring high sound quality
to everything I listen to,
whether it's music, podcasts,
or the haunted house sound effects
I required to fall asleep at night.
Plus, they're comfortable
to wear thanks to
optimized gel tips that adapt
to the contours of my ears.
This design helps them
stay put no matter what,
even if you're exercising, or in my case,
telling the Wisecrack team that I will not
practice TikTok dances
while the camera's rolling.
Raycon's everyday earbuds
offer eight hours of play time
and a 32-hour battery life,
so you can get through an
entire work day of Zoom calls
without worrying they'll cut out.
And that's just one of
the reasons they have more
than 48,005 star reviews.
Another reason, Raycon's
everyday earbuds offer
quality audio at half the
price of other premium brands.
Click the link in the description or go to
buyraycon.com/wisecrack to
get 15% off your purchase.
That's buyraycon.com/wisecrack
to get 15% off.
Now, back to the show.
Now, "The Batman" shows
Gotham as a city where
lies and concealment are so common,
they're practically part
of the infrastructure.
On a most obvious level,
there's Batman's steadfast
refusal to view his identity
to anyone, even to a
fellow leather enthusiast.
- Who are you under there?
- But the shadowy edges of Gotham
are brought into sharp focus by the film's
also masked villain, The Riddler.
He repeatedly states his grand project,
to shine a light on all the city's lies.
He's targeting the rich and powerful
for their various deceits,
which range from funding
sketchy nightclubs
to faking a giant drug bust.
And the most egregious deceit
is also the most widespread.
The city's elite have straight up
looted the Gotham Renewal fund,
which the Wayne family established to help
clean up the town.
And by the time we get to
the film's final, big reveal,
that a mafia-esque kingpin is puppeteering
Gotham's entire government,
it's clear that these widely accepted lies
go all the way to the top.
All this deceit from the
city's rich and powerful
made us think of Plato's
concept of the noble lie.
As explored in a controversial
paragraph of his book,
"The Republic," he explains
that rulers will need a throng
of lies and deceptions for
the benefits of the ruled.
Basically, a noble lie is an untruth
that a society's leaders
use to persuade their
citizens to fall into line,
all in the name of keeping
their society functioning.
A common noble lie is that
a given country's land
inherently belongs to its people,
even if that land was actually stolen.
A simple way of thinking of a
noble lie is the way parents
might be dishonest with their
child for their own good.
Plato basically thought that
such lies could be justified
if they served moral ends and means.
Modern philosophers like Leo
Straus have endorsed noble lies
as necessary for social cohesion.
It's good to keep people
united in their ideology,
even if that ideology
is falsely constructed.
And we see a pretty perverted
version of the noble lie
in "The Batman" where a
government filled with apparently
good, honest leaders is revealed
to be a giant masquerade.
These leaders have long pretended
to be genuinely invested
in Gotham's Renewal, when in actuality,
the Wayne funds were treated
as a cash grab for corruption.
The not so noble why,
that Thomas Wayne's funds
are being used to help the city flourish,
couldn't be further from the truth.
Gotham's politicians
get to blame the city's
criminal underworld for all the crime
and economic problems,
while all the while,
working alongside those
very criminals to ensure
that they're both making
money hand over fist.
And it's effective.
The smoke and mirrors of the
Gotham Renewal Project and the
lingering specter of
the criminal underworld
have kept the people
distracted while the select few
continue to enjoy their money and power.
The lie has arguably
fostered social cohesion,
although probably not as effectively
as, say, actually investing
in your city's infrastructure
and social services, but hey, I digress.
And throughout the movie,
we see more noble lies,
but on a smaller scale.
For example, we learned
that Batman's dad went
to great lengths to maintain
his wife's reputation.
Eventually, this led him
to send a seedy crime boss
to intimidate an
investigative reporter who was
gonna publish a story about
the less savory details
of his wife's personal history.
As usually happens when you
hire your local crime boss
for a freelance gig that
this resulted in murder,
all of which is sounding not super noble.
In tandem with this revelation,
we also see that Batman's vision
of his father as the ultimate pinnacle
of human goodness has
too been a noble lie.
Alfred admits that he didn't
tell Batman the truth about his
father because he knew little Bruce
desperately needed to believe in his
dad's unimpeachable greatness.
Here, it's worth noting
a choice that strikes us
as the movie's biggest shortcoming,
its refusal to double down on sullying
the image of Thomas Wayne.
See, at first, Batman thinks
that his dad intended to
have the reporter killed,
a horrifying prospect that
would tarnish Thomas's legacy.
However, he quickly learns that
all Thomas wanted to do was
scare the reporter, rather than kill him,
all in the name of protecting his wife.
What's more, Thomas was racked
with guilt in the aftermath
of the murder.
In fact, Alfred even says that
Thomas was planning to go to
the police and that this
may have been the reason
he himself was killed.
This felt like a bit of a
cop-out and a missed opportunity
to really complicate the Wayne
legacy in an interesting way.
Importantly, making Thomas
Wayne a capital B bad guy
would've created some nice
mirroring in the two threads
of the plot.
We'd have to watch
Batman personally reckon
with the same thing the city
of Gotham is on a larger scale,
the fact that the people
they admired most were
actually super sus and blatantly immoral.
Instead, it's like everybody else got
Santa spoiled for them
while Batman just found out
that Santa made one really
bad choice in the '80s.
So, what happens when
noble lies become intrinsic
to a given society's functioning?
Kind of like your increasingly
elaborate explanation
about why you got home late from school,
which had nothing at
all to do with the eight
bong rips at Cory's house.
Lies tend to beget more lies.
A lie then about the
city's biggest drug bust
then begets another lie,
that the busted drug
ring has been shut down,
when in actuality,
it's continued to flourish
by bribing public officials.
And as The Riddler reveals
the total dishonesty
of each public figure,
he starts to show how this
cycle of deceit has eaten
away at the foundation of
Gotham's civil society.
By the end of the film,
we learned that just about
every powerful person employed
by the city of Gotham
has accommodated the lies
and corruption necessary
to maintain their of power.
So, obviously, the rich
and influential are
super duper guilty, although
certainly not deserving
of having their faces devoured by rats.
But by the end, The Riddler
becomes even more radical,
suggesting that all of Gotham
is culpable for blindly
accepting the lies fed
to them by politicians
and thus are complicit
in the creation of this
deceitful society.
The film itself reflects some sense
of communal responsibility,
showing the solemn beginning
of a funeral for the mayor
where presumably nobody
was planning to mention
those leaked photos of him
with a young woman who had been battered.
But when Riddler escalates his attack
to target the entire city of Gotham,
things start feeling a little religious,
and not just because the song "Ave Maria"
pops up at least twice in the film.
See, by the Riddler's estimation,
the sense of the city's
leaders, and consequently,
its people are too heinous
for Gotham society to ever be redeemed.
That's why he decides to flood
the whole place, ironically,
by destroying some of the city's
actually functional infrastructure.
This can't help but make us
think of the Old Testament
God and the whole
flooding the goddamn world
because people were
behaving immorally thing.
As if it wasn't harsh enough,
God additionally rained burning sulfur
on the city of Sodom specifically
for the reason The Riddler floods Gotham.
It was a corrupt place
that failed to use its
resources to take care of
its most vulnerable citizens.
These evocations are anything but subtle.
And don't even get us
started on the whole sins
of the father theme
throughout the movie, too.
But, back to The Riddler.
He's a bad guy for a reason.
Where he sees an unredeemable society
or an unredeemable family,
Batman sees something else entirely.
To understand, let's track
Batman's personal arc
in the film.
He starts off really stoked
on the idea of vengeance,
believing that the best
way to keep people safe is
by A, giving them
something to fear, and B,
making sure people are held accountable
for their actions with violence.
He might not be drowning an entire city,
but this approach is not unlike
the Riddler's Old Testament vibes.
But throughout the film,
this approach to making
society a better place
is called into question,
not the least of which when
The Riddler tells Batman
that he has been an essential player
in the villain's deranged plot
and even says that they
are basically teammates.
But the validity of vengeance
as a guiding moral compass
is called into question
most explicitly when Batman
faces off against The Riddler's snipers
who have been shooting into a crowd.
One of the snipers, when asked
his name, replies vengeance,
thus mirroring Batman's
ideology back at him.
Obviously, sharing the same
mantra as a banana's group
of snipers isn't a good look,
so it's no surprise that
our hero ultimately settles
on a different view.
He decides that rather than
needing someone to fear,
the people of Gotham really
need someone to believe in,
someone to inspire hope.
And as he saves people from
The Riddler's giant flood,
Batman becomes that guy.
In the process, he also reads
kind of like a Jesus figure
to The Riddler's Old Testament God,
the brave guy willing to
make enormous sacrifices
and even risk death in
order to redeem a world
filled with sinners,
someone who wants justice
more than he does vengeance.
- The answer's justice
- But what do you guys think?
Can noble lies be a justifiable
way to keep any given
society humming along?
Would you rather not know
just how deeply corrupt
the rich and powerful are?
Let us know in the comments.
Big old thanks to our
patrons for all your support
and be sure to check out our podcast.
Punch that subscribe button like it's
a corrupt civil servant profiteering
off a local drug crisis and
don't forget to ring that bell.
And, as always, thanks for watching.
Peace.
(upbeat electronic music)